miley cyrus is gearing up to drop new
music and
she's clearly moving on and one year to
the day it was announced she and husband
liam hemsworth
called it quits
a whirlwind of change a source tells us
this has been a huge year
with tough challenges for miley we're
told after their separation
miley and liam spoke very little and all
communication was about splitting their
things in property
our source says miley and liam haven't
been in touch for months which is for
the best
because they both needed this time to
heal and move on
miley did just that with cody simpson
the couple of 10 months
is going strong
[Music]
they live together miley reportedly just
bought a 5 million dollar mansion in the
same neighborhood as the kardashians
and they're not shy about showing off on
social media
[Music]
with cody letting everyone know he's in
love with his best friend
cody and miley were friends for years
and it seems his feelings for her go way
back
check out this interview from 2012.
molly science has always been
always been my my childhood celebrity
crush
i knew all the words to a song i'm not
gonna lie
the pair reconnected after she split
with liam bonding over their love of
music
a source close to miley says she
couldn't be happier
another major life change i've been
sober sober for the past
six months riley stopped drinking and
using marijuana after needing a vocal
cord surgery last november
our source says the decision has made
her more present in her relationship
with cody
and has changed the way she thinks about
life it's been really important for me
over the last you know over the last
year um living a sober lifestyle
we'll get a peek at her new music
mindset when she releases her first song
in nearly a year
midnight sky this friday
[Music]
we're told her new music will be very
personal and that she's working on an
album
her last full record was in 2017.